maybe you're in california see someone  speeding down the road in a convertible  porsche and you think oh man what a  lucky bastard the first thing i think  you need to understand is that these  people that you're comparing yourself to  you don't really know you see they're  shiny outside but you don't see the  reality of their life the truth of the  matter is that he's thinking about  wrapping his expensive sports car around  the next cement pillar that he comes  close to you can't tell and people have  hard lives and and even people who are  comparatively fortunate have hard lives  and the ideal  that you're observing that makes you  jealous and resentful is in large part  an illusion that's created by your own  mind